This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Alice.
And I'm Neil. Could you lend me some Dosh Neil?
Sure, how much do you need?
A couple of smackers.
You'll send you a bit strange today, Alice.
Yes, I know, Neil.
Slang or informal language used by a particular group
is the subject of today's show.
And I was just demonstrating a couple of slang words that mean money.
Dosh is a general term for money, and a smacker is a British pound or US dollar.
Okay, so Cockney rhyming slang is a type of slang.
It's a coded language invented in the 19th century by Cockneys.
So they could speak in front of the police without being understood.
And still on the subject of money, I have a question for you, Alice.
Oh, okay.
What's Cockney rhyming slang for money?
Is it a bread, b honey or c-dough?
I think it's a bread.
I bet you didn't know Neil that I'm a Cockney.
I don't add a manoeuvre, Alice. That's a pork pie.
Adam and Eve means believe and pork pie means lie.
Actually, you're right. I'm not a Cockney.
To be considered a Cockney, you need to be born
within hearing distance of the bells of St Mary Lebo Church
in what is now the city of London.
Indeed. Now slang, as we've said, is colloquial or informal language
and it's characteristic of specific social groups.
We usually use it in informal conversation
rather than in writing or more formal situations like a job interview.
We change the way we speak so that what we say is appropriate
for a particular situation.
So you surprised me earlier, Alice, by talking about
Dosh and smackers because it didn't seem appropriate
for presenting the show.
Slang use is often frowned upon or disapproved of.
Let's listen to Jonathan Green, a lexicographer of slang,
talking about who uses slang and how this has changed.
Here he is on the Radio 4 programme Word of Mouth.
Slang does have a bad reputation and I would say this comes
from its earliest collection which was of criminal slang
in the 1500s in the 16th century and it was associated with bad people
and inevitably that has lingered.
But now in the last 40-50 years it's changed the definitions
tend to stress different and jocular, funny, humorous,
inventive that kind of thing.
So we have records of 16th century slang in collections or dictionaries.
Words used by criminals as a code so they could talk without being understood
and this bad reputation has lingered or been slow to disappear.
But for the last 50 years we've been using slang to be funny and creative
as well as to show belonging to a particular group
and apparently we're very creative when talking about drinking and being drunk.
The slang word booze meaning alcohol comes from the 13th century Dutch word
and there are hundreds of slang expressions to talk about drink and being drunk
on the source in your cups half-cut hammered, squiffy tipsy, wasted,
legless and many many more that are far too rude to mention in this programme.
Yes. So while these terms might not be strictly acceptable
or appropriate in formal context they aren't offensive,
they are often amusing and help people bond in social groups.
By contrast, swear words or profanity means rude language that offends or upsets people
and I'm not going to give any examples because that would be inappropriate and impolite, Alice.
Okay, let's listen now to Jonathan Green and presenter Michael Rosen
talking about jargon, another type of in-group language.
jargon what I would call is small-o occupational small-p professional slang it's closed off
environment. You get legal jargon, you get a naval jargon I've been reading and
Patrick O'Brien recently and that's a wash with butter plates and fidying the day.
This is radio four Jonathan, be careful. Jonathan Green in another segment of the BBC Radio Four
programme word of mouth. So he says jargon is occupational and professional meaning people speak
at work for example lawyers and sailors. A futter plate is I believe an iron plate
attached to the top of a ship's mast but I don't know much about this subject.
That's the idea though jargon is the technical language belonging to a specific group
and to outsiders this jargon is often hard to understand.
Yes and here in the studio I can use all the radio jargon that I liked look at my
faders here Alice going down up and up and up and I'm just testing our levels.
Come on leave the fader alone it controls the level of sound on a studio deck.
Now it's time for the answer to today's quiz question Neil.
I asked you what's Cockney rhyming slang for money? Is it A, bread, B, honey or C, dough?
And I said A, bread.
In you were right Alice Cockney rhyming slang uses just the first word of a phrase that rhymes
with the word we're trying to disguise. So money becomes bread and honey but we just say bread.
Okay so let's recap on the words we've learnt today. They are slang,
Dosh, smacker, Cockney rhyming slang, colloquial, frowned upon, lingered, booze, swear, profanity, jargon.
Well that's the end of today's 6 Minute English please join us again soon.
Bye bye.